[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長ですあの最近まであれば tb さんの企画で夏川店心理買っ
たら1000万円っていう客があったんですけどもその企画で僕の声のケースティガー
の出場してなんですけども
ボクシングを習いに行ってたわけですよ木刀後半のケースでも体重が一緒で同じ階級な
んで
zero1ちゃスパーリングとかできたらいいなと思って見て練習しすぎ
でまだな音ね拳ダブりまくったぜそのプロの方と比べたら全然なんですけども素人なり
にはめちゃくちゃ頑張って練習とか背中持つ美高くなっちゃってなんか
ボクシング用のグローブ買ったりこのパターンでまずは浮霊を使ったり色々したんです
けどもなぜかその勢いでこちら
言語までか釣れましたなんで買ったんだろ自分でもよくわかんないんですけどもたば爪
が高すぎて活用
ましたね結局ボクシングってゴングがあって始まり
ゴングがあって終わるそういうスポーツのでこれが音が弾まないんだなぁと思ったとか
釣れました
プレリーファイ
ルサールで5分買っちゃったんですけども当然があってからこそできる道があると思い
まして今回寸日をさせていただきました
紹介いたします相手コーナーよりプレイせずの従卒 mitre 今バイトは今ミニー
ていい笑顔が不気味で臭い
伝説の財布真っ青とかじゃあねーねー
[音楽]
[拍手]
20生姜てる先生
一発てようでいかん
ダーツ水ましては青コーナー阿部ら tv なんか電車に買ったら1000万円客が肇
社長と1週間猛特訓してきた
不屈のファイター3簿心も僕主義捧げ
来年は誰と戦うのかを願掛けしておりますゲイ
ません
[拍手]
[音楽]
はいというわけでその今先週まずはあっちの方よろしくお願います
というわけで今回の試合はボクシングケースで行う
1ラウンド店
6時間でがちなチェックラックはれますもう2人がネス待ってる間にとんねん
時代は開設されますサラダや play
ブーバーこれで撮っちゃいますかあっで
はいありがとうございますまあ健介選手ボクシングずっと頑張って歯ないこと
ボクシング政治というかパリターキッシュから出てきたと思うんですけどもできました
初知っておりますあなたロングがなるといてもたってもいられないと思うでしょ
思ったわけですよ僕はそこ授業つけたんですよね図2ゴング鳴っても
うるさっくらいしか思えないんですけどもはや号機腹案発的にセットで入ってしまうと
僕新景品者としての感謝しんじゃこりゃ見てみたいなと言うけどまぁしまして対する
たり選手
ok どうですか辻氏
しかないですね何というかわかんですけどいいまたてねし何が振れています校
はーいおっねむにはとても深いことが出てる時に蓄えたエネルギーの羽根っていうのは
すごいということでボング相当うるさいです
[音楽]
この場で mercer
ブーバーてるんですっ
見えてると思うんですよあともうを起こしてあげるかのようにバーンとな good
エイミーする
ブーバー鋭敏で言う言葉をいただきましたらどうでしょうか
今ミックスああああヌー
よろしくお願い致します
では2人ともほとんどいろんなコーナーに下がってください電車描けますねはい
4時から朝5時半で本当にばカードへ
甘いあーが食べて航空法がの試合会場でございますバッハ
こちらにあるのがゴングそしてある加工ねんって初め
ほぼところ柿釉車 new ヨハネが市で何を見せるのか
お金は彼は左ストレートに住んでくださいあは彼はなぁ
牧神ケーキがあるここで反射審議見せられるかロングの音で体をください
kk
[音楽]
[拍手]
もういいか寿司やはりそうですね殺し合いまずは出ることから始まるのでと言うともう
しっかりみてくださいこれでゴングの合図でファイト秋パンツァーでの方が勝ちです
時間目制御盤ランドで庁舎をどちらになるのでしょうか
おそらく二人とももう朝5時眠いと思いますがちゃんと出てくださいね
自然な日本語に1人が起きているのかうぇい
おやすみなさいと
えっ
ん
[音楽]
ううっうぅうう
さあシアン始まり5分が経過しました
wh
早いですパンする経歴でし
まだ寝れなそうですねこの睡眠の浅さがどう出るか誰だねブジーに深ければ深い報道
コングの音に反応がを含めてしまいましたが
レフリーの弾み先週まだ慣らしませんしっかり止めて下さいおやすみなさい
[音楽]
あっ
フープ風
goo
[音楽]
プー
クラリー
[音楽]
[拍手]
持って
を
[音楽]
teap 2
car
wh
悪い
ポイッ
売れ
[ __ ]色いない数
盲学校したう